how's the whole school see with
bloodbath basically just two defenses
playing out of their mind then yeah we
just found a way to win you know and
that says so much about our team see
that we've had so many so many weeks now
where we've been efficient and we're
moving the chains third day on all these
kind of things and then we we ran into
this team and for whatever reason
tonight you know it was just some nights
are just tougher than others right you
know what I'm saying and this was one of
those nights it really wasn't an
old-school AFC West bloodbath I've seen
old-school AFC West blood baths I mean
for long stretches it was a boring game
it had some late lead changes that made
it exciting it wasn't a bloodbath it was
just you know hey one offense was worse
than the other one offense ultimately
had a harder time moving the football
when it mattered and I got to give
derrick karr credit ten play 75-yard
Drive gets the ball down the field gets
the game-winning touchdown and then the
defense holds on and the Raiders win and
you mentioned this earlier big cat and
we've decided to broaden the lens a
little bit as we consider coach of the
year we're halfway through the season
and we have seen some teams that have
over achieved and that really is the
loose standard for the voters not that
it's articulating where the thing about
these postseason awards from the AP
there's no there's no rule there's no
guidance coach of the year whatever you
think coach of the year is and it does
become the coach who most dramatically
exceeds the pre-existing expectations
and I think we're onto something with
Jon Gruden has potential coach of the
year if they make it to the playoffs how
about some other candidates I want to
get your reaction to these Sean B armor
the bills I think Sean McDermott is in
the discussion I probably wouldn't have
him I wrote down I won't have them in my
top five right now because I think the
Bills have and I love the bills I love
the people of Buffalo but I think they
have benefited from a slightly soft
schedule so while they're gonna probably
make the playoffs and I like what
they're building there I don't think
he's my coach of the year there's
another category that I think becomes
relevant this year it's not just coach
who most exceeds what we expected before
the season
there's also coaches who have handled
adversity in season that dramatically
decreased expectations and then they
exceeded that barrier like a Mike Tomlin
we wouldn't have thought of him
the coach that your candidate at four
and four if we'd heard back in September
that the steel is gonna be four and four
when you consider all the crap they've
been through to get to four and four if
they get to the playoffs Tomlin's got to
be considered absolutely my Tommen is
definitely on the you know list
somewhere I'd probably like 5 6 if the
Steelers can make the playoffs I think
he definitely has a good case for coach
of the year because of what you just
mentioned both the offseason with the
Le'Veon Bell with the Antonio Brown and
then Big Ben getting hurt and having to
go in the Mason Rudolph getting hurt
he's kept that team together the fact
that they are four and four and have a
huge game on Sunday against the Rams
were if they win that game they are now
in a spot where they can be that six you
know team in the AFC wild card race a
similar one to that Mike Sean Peyton
Teddy Bridgewater comes in
drew Brees goes out in the second week
Teddy Bridgewater comes in they way they
keep winning games they've been
phenomenal if the New Orleans Saints get
the number one seed and you and you look
back and you say they got the number one
seed into in Drew Brees missed five
games or whatever it was I think he gets
a conversation for Coach dears and was
Ron Rivera if the Panthers make the
playoffs and Cam Newton is out for this
long in the season I think he also is a
candidate for Coach deer but I think
there's one name that is a slam-dunk
ahead of Jon Gruden right now and I
think Jong Un's probably might three
right now if I had to put it two would
be Frank Reich because of the Andrew
Luck situation one it's gonna be Kyle
Shanahan if the 49ers keep winning Kyle
Shanahan will win coach the year and he
will be much deserved to have that
because he went through a lot last year
last year was supposed to be the year
they had been playing phenomenal
football having Jimmy grapple come back
from a torn ACL and and putting that
team on the right path and having them
be as dominant as they looked
I think Kyle Shanahan is your coach the
year halfway through the season I agree
with you halfway through the season but
we look at the upcoming schedule for the
49ers he's gonna earn it if he wins it
and if this team ends up being the 1
seed they will have proven themselves
because they play the Packers they play
the Saints they play the Ravens have the
Rams again they have the Seahawks
twice this schedule gets very difficult
down the stretch
there's a there's a way these dominoes
fall big cat where they end up not even
getting a buy so I think they need the
one seat of the to seat for Shanahan to
be a viable candidate let me throw a
couple others out there before we run
out of time we mentioned Matt Lafleur
when we talked about this last segment I
mean exceeding expectations who would
have thought the Packers would be this
good this quickly under a coach who
seemed to be in over his head
coming into the job with Aaron Rodgers
Andy Reid handling the Patrick mahomes
injury resisting the temptation to put
him back on the field getting one win
out of that that deadly 2 pack at home
of the Packers and the Vikings if they
end up with a 2-seater the 1 seed Reid's
got to be considered I like that my last
one John Harbaugh if they if they get
the one seed John Harbaugh definitely
needs to be in the converse absolutely
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports